Let's get your Chrysler 300 key fob
programmed quickly. This video covers
remote pairing for Chrysler 300 models
from 2005 to 2023.
First, ensure you have your key fob and
the vehicle key. The basic principle
involves cycling the ignition to enter
programming mode and synchronizing the
fob with the car's immobilizer and body
control module using a specific
sequence. Remember, precise timing is
crucial. Delays can reset the process.
Each fob has a unique code and
reprogramming overwrites old codes,
preventing duplicates. This guide
focuses on DIY methods applicable to
most models, but variations exist
depending on the year. If this process
fails, you will have to take it to a
professional, which will have a cost
associated. Make sure your car is in a
secure location to avoid any kind of
signal interference and prevent any kind
of theft.
Here's the most common programming
method for your Chrysler 300 key fob.
First, insert your key into the
ignition. Turn the ignition to the onr
run position, but do not start the
engine. Within 4 seconds of turning the
key to onr run, press and hold the lock
button on the key fob for 1 second, then
release it. Repeat this process for all
key fobs you want to program up to a
maximum of four. After programming all
fobs, turn the ignition off. Finally,
test each key fob to ensure it's working
correctly. If you have a newer 2015 or
later model with UK Connectnect, you
might be able to pair via the UK
Connectnect app if your vehicle's
firmware is up to date. Scan the QR code
on the fob and pair via Bluetooth in the
vehicle's settings. For troubleshooting
tips, first ensure the fob battery isn't
dead. Check the Chrysler owner's manual
for your specific model year for any
specific steps or variations.
If programming fails repeatedly,
consider visiting a dealership,
especially for high mileage vehicles
that may have BCM wear. Dealerships can
also help if the system locks you out
during DIY attempts.